unemployment is rising as the economic
consequences of lockdown begin to bite
and today the Labour Party is warning
about a crunch date in less than three
weeks when mass redundancies could begin
well joining us from Westminster evening
shadow work and pensions secretary
Jonathan Rennell and thank you for being
on the program mr. Reynolds what exactly
is it that Labour is warning about good
morning sir the impact on unemployment
of this crisis really cannot be
overestimated we already have a claimant
count at 2.8 million we've had another
half a million universal credit
applications on top of that and we know
that young people only half of young
people who are eligible for out of work
benefits will claim them so it's
possible actually already that
unemployment is the highest that it's
ever been and the government cannot be
slow to act in response to that in
particular we need a jobs budget the
focus should be jobs jobs and jobs again
and crucially things like the furlough
scheme cannot be a one-size-fits-all
scheme if you look around the world a
lot of countries are acting flexibly we
need to see that in this country for
sectors that are still very much
affected by the crisis we also need to
see the government get directly involved
in the business of creating jobs
something like the Future Jobs Fund
which we saw after the financial crisis
the government guaranteeing people work
if they've been out of work for a
significant period of time that's the
kind of action that we need because we
know that the long-term effects of an
employment scar people for many years
after the experience of it itself I just
wonder if some of what you're calling
for the government is effectively
already doing you're saying they're
about a sector specific attitude towards
the furlough scheme but the Chancellor
merci Sudak said this week it's not
sustainable for the scheme to be
sustained indefinitely there are other
ways we can support the labor market
including direct fiscal support to those
particular industries most affected I
mean that sounds like the kind of
tailored support that you're calling for
and if you're asking for the government
to do something quickly well we're
expecting this speech now from the prime
minister next week where he's announcing
a building blitz to get the economy
restarted after coronavirus though isn't
what you're saying already in the
pipeline I'm afraid I don't think it is
I mean first of all on on build build
build we've heard things like that
before I mean I remember the march of
the makers 10 years ago what did we see
house building as its lowest of the last
decade since the second world war
capital investment in in Yorkshire in
the Midlands half of that of what it is
in London but
going back to the point around the
furlough scheme if the claimant council
already over three million and we have
over nine million people furloughed as
employers have to make contributions as
that part of the program starts the
danger is many of those people will
simply be made redundant if you look
around the world New Zealand has
extended its furlough scheme its wage
subsidy scheme to any business still
affected by a loss of revenue from the
crisis if you look at Spain or Italy
they're extending it to areas like
hospitality and tourism that are still
affected that's the kind of approach
that we need but it's only one part of
it alongside that bring forward
investment decisions make sure people
young people are kept in education
otherwise 800,000 young people will
enter the labor market this summer
that's worked in the past use the Future
Jobs Fund as a template for that just to
be clear then is labor calling for the
furlough scheme to be extended yes it
should be extended not in a universal
way but in a sector specific way to make
sure that as we continue through this
crisis we don't see those people
currently Furr Lord simply made
redundant and put further on to the
claimant camp okay now and you mentioned
about the issues around education is
something that we're going to be
exploring in the program later on I'm
visited a school this week where the
head teacher said that part of the issue
is parents are effectively too scared to
send their children back to school and
many pupils
he's worried it will be very frightened
when they do eventually return to the
classroom does labor need to take a bit
more responsibility for this it feels to
me like you've been quite slow in
calling for schools to reopen to more
pupils Kirsten mow hesitating and Prime
Minister's Questions to say that it's
safe to send children back should you
have done more to get schools reopened
no I don't think that's fair Sophie
everybody wants schools to go back the
impact on inequality of children being
off school for so long eyes I see and I
worry about it in terms of my own
children everybody should want schools
back but the only way to do that is to
convince parents that it's safe to work
with councils to work with Academy
trusts to work with the teaching unions
to find a way to do that only the
government can lead on that that's
pretty obvious but at the same time you
we have offered we suggested a task
force to get people to get this sorted
to make sure schools were safe to go
back and that people would feel that it
is safe to do so but the lack of
leadership from the government on this
real
has been a spectacular failure they've
got to take responsibility for it
they've been slow even to make sure that
people have the resources they require
to learn at home but no one should doubt
the impact of children not being at
school is incredibly severe on them but
the government has to lead on getting
them back so is it safe for children to
return to school now it will always be
about managing risks until we have a
vaccine it will always be about managing
risks in whatever sphere we are talking
about but there are ways the government
look at the approach for instance to the
the Nightingale hospitals that were set
up where's the equivalent approach in
education to that where's the
requisitioning of space to make sure we
can have bubble classrooms away from
traditional school buildings where's the
efforts to get resources to children at
home none of that has happened and the
responsibility for that is firmly at the
government's feet okay now you've got of
course a new shadow education secretary
in the party after Rebecca long Bailey
was sacked for tweeting a link to an
interview with the actress Maxine Peake
where she talked about what many would
consider to be an anti-semitic
conspiracy theory was Kirsten were right
to get rid of her well I have a lot of
time and respect for Becky and the job
that she was doing I want a broad base
shadow cabinet not because of party
unity by the way but because a strong
shadow cabinet reflects all the
viewpoints across yes the sharing of an
anti-semitic conspiracy theory I'm
afraid is not something that can be
ignored if people don't understand why
that was anti-semitic there's a lot of
resources available for people to
understand and find that out but we will
get no more chances we deserve no more
chances with the Jewish community to win
back the trust that has been lost and
Kia promised a zero tolerance I mean
that has to mean zero tolerance and I'm
afraid for that reason yes I'm afraid
that change had to be made actually
reflected slightly in your answer there
you know you want to work quite closely
with Rebecca long Bailey do you think
she has a blind spot on anti-semitism
where's me and this is a point more
generally I think that if anyone can't
understand what the problem is with an
article like that and I think it's
important to say you know who Maxine
Peake has apologised for for any
reference that was given within that
interview throughout time there has been
a strand of anti-semitism which has been
about blaming Jewish people for all the
problems in the world and a modern
incarnation of that
is simply replacing Jews with Israel now
that is something that's in the Labor
Party's own guidance that we send out on
anti-semitism and if someone is looking
at the terrible scenes in America and
somehow trying to change the blame for
that to Israel I mean the anti-semitic
warning lights should be flashing to
anyone who who sees that in print or
hears something like that so more
broadly people have to understand but
why this is such an issue and do you
think that Rebecca long Bailey perhaps
did not previously understand that I'm
not sure to be honest I when I saw the
article that had been shared I've got to
say I gasped I caught my breath I
assumed perhaps it hadn't been read in
an apology week forthcoming I don't know
exactly you know why that is still a
player on Twitter but you know there's
no doubt it is an anti-semitic
conspiracy theory and we promise zero
tolerance and that has to be what we we
practice and preach okay now I just want
to talk about your brief as well as a
the shadow work and Pensions Secretary
now you've called for universal credit
to be scrapped given it has taken so
long to set up millions of people now
rely on it is it sensible to be calling
for an overhaul of the system at a time
when it's already under so much pressure
because of Coppa 19 I'm afraid I think
it is what you need from universal
credit or whatever replaces it is a
safety net a strong safety net that gets
people through crises like this one but
also times when they've lost their job
or they're too ill to work and that is
not what Universal Credit provides I
mean the figures out last week nearly
three and a half million British people
dependent on food charity or food banks
to get by as six million British people
having to have smaller portions for
their meals but they can't manage with
what they receive I want to stress as
well so we said during the crisis that
the changes we want to see the
government make are actually practical
changes to universal credit things like
scrubbing the two-child limit and the
benefit cap and crucially the five-week
wait so we've been pragmatic in what we
have asked for but going forward if we
need the kind of Social Security system
that we do need just to cope with the
changes of the impacts of technology on
people's jobs or or just a normal
situation where people get ill at times
and they need support from the system
Universal Credit just does not provide
that and at the same time I think the
brand the approach of universal credit
that very punitive sanctions based
approach that is not the right way
forward
one in their lives at some point may
need support from a social security
system and that is simply not what they
get from the universal credit I'm
interested to know about your own
intentions for the benefit system as
well because a few weeks ago you said
this I feel if you've made greater
contributions to the system there is an
argument that you should receive more
out of the system and kissed Armour when
he was the Director of Public
Prosecutions he actually increased jail
sentences the benefit sheet saying it's
vital that we take a tough stance on
this type of fraud and I'm determined to
see a clamp down on those who flout the
system so under a kiss Thomas leadership
here in you in the job is labor about to
get tough on benefits no I regret I do
not accept at all the kind of rhetoric
we once saw from people like George
Osborne about trying to be divisive in
terms of the Social Security system I
want to be absolutely clear what I'm
talking about
contributory benefits are a crucial part
of the existing system if you apply for
universal credit and you don't get it
because it's a means-tested benefit what
you will get instead if you paid your
National Insurance Contributions our
Jobseeker's Allowance that the national
insurance based benefits that we have in
the system now for the first time
because the government has failed to
operate those legacy benefits alongside
the increase in Universal Credit the
National Insurance level of support is
lower than the means-tested level of
support now that is completely
unacceptable 74 pounds a week is a not
sufficient compensation for the National
Insurance Contributions people have paid
so that is what I am talking about the
government's answer to that as you know
is simply to say and we can't upgrade
the system the computer says no that is
completely unacceptable this is not a
small part of the system hundreds of
thousands of people are dependent on
this aspect though because they don't
qualify for universal credit and they're
not getting what they need and they're
not getting what they deserve and when
we talk about finding a replacement for
universal credit we've got to consider
this respect of it as well because
people as you know are currently
eligible for both it's just if you claim
universal credit it will take away every
pound that you would get from a
contributory benefit so most people
don't claim both at the same time